hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast drug development and
approval in the US regulatory challenges
and opportunities for cannabis therapies
presented by Emily Leon Jeanne an
attorney at arrant Fox I am Judy Aurora
of lab roots and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by laberd's laberd's is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before it
began I'd like to remind everyone this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type their
questions into the drop down box it
appears on your screen
well answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing a
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming
Emily Leon Jeanne I will now turn the
presentation over to her thank you so
much Judy as Judy mentioned my name is
Emily Lea Jeanne and I'm an attorney at
the DC based law firm of Erin Fox I'm an
FDA regulatory attorney by training and
I joined the firm after working at the
FDA for about six years and I am
delighted to be joining you here today
to talk about the FDA drug approval
paradigm and what that might mean in the
cannabis industry and hopefully after
our presentation today you'll be able to
have an understanding of how FDA
regulates drugs
and some other kinds of products and
understanding how cannabis therapies may
and may not fit it within that
regulatory paradigm so as a preliminary
matter I think it'd be helpful just to
talk about what what it is that the FDA
does obviously I think folks know about
the regular regulation of foods and
drugs because that's in the title of the
agency but the FDA also has a very
wide-ranging
regulatory jurisdiction over a lot of
different kinds of products everything
from foods and drugs medical devices to
veterinary medicines and foods and my
personal favorite fun fact laser
pointers that cats use so they have a
lot of different things that the FDA
regulates and the kinds of controls that
the FDA imposes on those various
different categories is determined by
what kind of product it is under the
definitions of the Federal Food Drug and
Cosmetic Act and as I'll mention in just
a moment
the how the product is regulated and
what kind of regulatory bucket it falls
within is determined by what the
products quote intended you says so but
before we get to that I just wanted to
mention FDA's role in regulating
cannabis the FDA obviously oversees the
drug approval paradigm and the drug
approval pathway for any kind of
pharmaceutical including potential
cannabis therapies additionally FDA
provides scientific support and
oversight by conducting literature and
scientific reviews to support or make
recommendations to the Drug Enforcement
Administration and the Department of
Health and Human Services within which
the FDA sits regarding scheduling
determinations as you all are likely
aware
in the excuse me summer of 2016
DEA recently excuse me denied a petition
to reschedule cannabis excuse me
marijuana from a Schedule one drug to
potentially a lower schedule and part of
the DA's determination their rationale
for making that determination was based
on inputs and guidance from the FDA
reviewing the available scientific
literature additionally from the
scientific role FDA also oversees many
of the clinical trials and clinical
research that are conducted with
cannabis therapies and additionally the
FDA takes enforcement action it's been
in the form of sending warning letters
to companies that have been marketing
cannabis therapies with some fairly
egregious kinds of health claims and
you'll understand why if you don't
already you understand why that's an
issue momentarily once we start getting
into you can some of the definitions so
there are a lot of different definitions
within the Food Drug and Cosmetic Act
but for the purposes of our talk today
two of the ones that I wanted to discuss
are the definitions of drug and dietary
supplement because these are two
definitions that I think people are
there's a lot of confusion about and
where that line between a dietary
supplement and a drug where that line is
so a dietary supplement is a product
that has contains a vitamin mineral or
other botanical or any other kind of
dietary substance that is intended to so
we're getting back to that intended
language intended to supplement the diet
and of key importance here is the that a
dietary supplement cannot contain an
fda-approved drug or a drug that is
currently under investigation for which
there's
scientific literature is publicly
available so if something that would
otherwise be regulated or could be
regulated as a dietary supplement
contains a substance that is currently
under investigation for use in a drug it
is that product is automatically
excluded from the statutory definition
of dietary supplements as it's defined
under the Food Drug and Cosmetic Act so
moving along to drug the the way that
the this is kind of a partial definition
of drug but it's most relevant for our
purposes here today a drug is defined as
articles that are again intended for the
use in diagnosing curing mitigating
treating or preventing a disease it also
includes articles other than food that
are intended to affect the structure or
function of the body so a couple of
important distinctions between dietary
supplements and drugs are the the
statute that created the regulatory
classification of dietary supplement
very interestingly placed them as kind
of a subclass of foods so as I mentioned
earlier the way and the the types of
regulatory controls that the FDA imposes
on a particular product are driven by
what bucket it falls under and the way
that the enabling legislation it's
called Desha or de Shia depending on who
you ask
passed in 1994 puts dietary supplements
within the food bucket so there along
with that there's no pre-market approval
there are different kinds of
manufacturing and production
requirements different kinds of
registration requirements so and it's
very different than the way that FDA
regulates drugs which is what we'll be
spending most of our time today talking
about then another one of the key
distinctions and this again is based on
the way that the Food Drug and Cosmetic
Act defines these
types of products is that if a product
that would otherwise or could otherwise
be considered to be a dietary supplement
makes claims on the labeling and
labeling is not just what appears on the
bottle of of a product it includes
practically anything you say about the
product so includes information on a
website testimonials all those things so
labeling is defined very very broadly
and so if any of the labeling contains
any representations or claims that the
product is intended to diagnose cure
mitigate prevent or treat a disease it
de facto under the Food Drug and
Cosmetic Act becomes a drug even if
nothing else changes if just what you
say about the product is that it it's
going to prevent a disease or treat a
disease and again diseases is construed
very very broadly as well then it
automatically becomes a drug and that's
where a lot of cannabis companies have
gotten into some hot water in the past
when I mentioned the enforcement those
were the kinds of things
it was those claims that rendered the
products drugs and therefore unlawfully
marketed so moving along to the bulk of
our presentation today we're going to be
talking about FDA's regulatory paradigm
for approving drugs so there are a
number of different ways that a product
that a drug can be lawfully marketed in
the United States there are
over-the-counter drugs which essentially
have to comply with they're kind of like
recipes that FDA has issued and they're
all codified and the Code of Federal
Regulations and it states what kind of
active ingredients are allowed to be
used what kinds of information has to be
on the label
what kind of combinations of active
products can be used but if a product
complies with those
quote-unquote recipes also called
monographs an OTC drug may be lawfully
marketed over-the-counter then in terms
of the products that have to go through
a approval process at the FDA the the
one that we'll be talking about
primarily today is the new drug
application or NDA approval process and
that requires extensive safety and
efficacy data to support FDA approval
there are also something something
called the 505 b2 or paper NDA product
it's also technically a new drug
application but instead of relying upon
all that extensive clinical data it
relies upon the public scuse me
published literature and previous
findings by FDA of safety and efficacy
of another approved drug in that same
class or the similar drug so because
they rely instead of on clinical data
they're relying upon paper that's why
it's called the paper NDA and then
there's also the abbreviated new drug
application process and that is a
process that is used for generic drugs
so referencing what's called an
innovator drug the drug that was
approved under an NDA the sponsor of an
NDA or and can does not need to
replicate all of the clinical trials
that were used to support the initial
marketing in the NDA but instead they
just have to demonstrate that their
product is bio equivalent to basically
that it it interacts in the same way in
the body and gives the same clinical
benefit as the innovator drug that was
approved under the NTA so we're going to
be talking primarily about the envier
process because it's new drug
applications and I think that's that's
what's most applicable likely in the
cannabis space so that's we're gonna be
talking about today
so some facts about the approval of new
drug applications according to FDA's
estimate
it takes about anywhere between 8 and 10
years following preclinical work to
develop to do the requisite studying and
clinical research that is necessary to
demonstrate that a drug is safe and
effective to be approved by the FDA and
so as this slide mentioned that includes
some early lab testing as well as animal
testing and then much of it involves the
clinical trials with human subjects so
this is a graphic describing the port
raising the process for how a drug
application proceeds through the FDA
approval process so of course beginning
begins with preclinical meaning not in
human subject types of research
followed by meetings with the FDA to do
basically scope out the investigational
new drug application followed by
clinical trials and then the submission
of the new drug application and then for
the lucky few who make it through that
far the FDA approval so we're going to
be going through each of these stages in
a little bit more detail so with the
investigational new drug application
essentially it is intended for any drug
that that you want to study in in humans
and that you went to market as a drug
meaning you want to market it as being
intended to diagnose cure mitigate
prevent a disease before initiating
clinical trials you need to submit and
have approved an investigational new
drug application or an IND and so the
IND is the culmination of successful
preclinical development meaning all of
the testing that was done leading up to
human clinical trials
and it's the vehicle through which
sponsors obtain FDA approval to begin
the clinical the clinical research with
the drug so one of the things to mention
is that FDA is red
they're pretty emphatic and it also
behooves the sponsors that that
companies should interact early
frequently and regularly with the FDA as
they are going through the FT through
the drug approval process so talking
about the I and D at the IND stage there
are something called the pre-ind
meetings which as you would imagine
involves meeting with the FDA before you
submit the IND to basically reach an
agreement with the agency about the
format of the IND and at that point FDA
will request any additional information
that they might want talk about the kind
of clinical testing that needs to happen
to discuss the product characterization
issues and the scope and the design of
the Phase one clinical trials so I've
been using some the term sponsor and
using some of these terminologies so
just to kind of clarify what I mean here
so these are some of the the players in
this process the sponsor is an FDA
language that's the company that is
technically it could be if just a person
but typically a company that is
responsible for and initiates the
clinical investigation with the drug
then the investigator is the individual
who actually conducts the clinical
investigations contract research
organizations or CRO s most companies
don't actually do their clinical trials
in house they will contract with
organizations that have expertise in
this area and have done this many many
times before and so there's some what
a lot of fact most times sponsors will
outsource the the conduct of the
clinical trials to a CRO
additionally there are institutional
review boards or IRB s which is the
independent body that is set up to
evaluate and review clinical studies
paying particular attention to
protection of the human subjects making
sure that there's informed consents
making sure that the clinical trials are
being run appropriately then the term
subject is the term that is used for the
for the individual who is participating
in the clinical trials and then of
course there's the the FDA that oversees
all of it
so the sponsors investigators Ciara's
and I RPS are all subject to FDA
inspection after the IND
is has been filed not only are they
subject to inspection but they are
inspected almost all the time and not
only can failure to comply with FDA's
IND and clinical research requirements
not only can that end up you know
receiving a warning letter but if there
are some major issues that FDA finds
they can either place a clinical hold on
the current that study or also they
could prevent future applications for
other drugs from from moving forward if
the the if the deficiency is serious
enough so what actually goes into an IND
I'm not gonna run through all of these
things but if a few things to highlight
of course there's the background
information on the sponsor and about the
drug but of great importance are the
study protocols and on the next slide
we'll talk about what exactly what the
study protocols are but it's basically
how you plan to how the company plans to
run its clinical trials in addition
there
is FTA requires that sponsors submit
what are called CMC's the chemistry
manufacturing and control information
this is essentially how the active
ingredient is being manufactured and
that active ingredient meaning the
ingredient that produces the the drug
effect of the intended effect of that
drug and then the drug product itself
meaning the the total drug product
additionally labeling for
investigational new drugs there's
certain specific labeling requirements
basically saying this is for
investigational use only and then in
addition as part of the submission
sponsors are required to submit
pharmacology and toxicology information
data that was collected during the
preclinical phase and then if there's
any other previous human experience with
the drug that should also be submitted
so the study protocols which are pretty
key in getting an IND approved of course
you have to say what your point is what
what you what your goal is and how
you're going to measure it so the
objectives of the study and the primary
and secondary endpoints how are you
going to determine whether the product
is safe and effective for the intended
indication measures that are intended to
monitor the not only the effectiveness
but also the safety in humans as well as
the proposed statistical analysis that
the sponsor plans to use in evaluating
the drug safety and efficacy
so after FDA has approved an IND you
can't just go ahead and get started with
the clinical trials you have to wait 30
days before initiating the clinical
trials and there's oftentimes FDA asked
for changes tweaks and that can
sometimes cause some delays sometimes
folks have to go back to the drawing
board
and again this this underscores the
importance of of having those pre-ind
meetings to work with FDA proactively to
identify any potential hiccups before
you get too far down the road and end up
submitting your IND and then
FDA asked for changes there afterwards
so FDA can issue a clinical hold on any
sort of proposed ongoing clinical trials
you know as I mentioned for if there's
any new data that has discovered any
potential safety concerns and as well as
as I mentioned earlier at the if any of
the investigations by FDA reveal any
major deficiencies as well and there is
a very strict prohibition against
advertising or promoting in any way an
investigational new truck so moving
right along so once once an IND is
approved we get to hop to clinical
trials and so there are just well there
are typically three phases of clinical
trials although sometimes and this is
something that can be worked out during
the IND phase sometimes the different
phases can be combined phase 1 phase 2
phase 2 phase 3 and again it depends on
the drug and it depends on the
particular study proposed and so as
listed here phase 1 very very small
number of humans participating in those
trials phase 2 you move it up a little
bit to a few hundred and then phase 3 is
where that sort becomes used more
broadly and it's usually in the
thousands of of clinical subjects so the
whole purpose of phase 1 studies are
it's the first time that it's been used
in humans and it is intended to figure
out how the drug is metabolized what the
pharmacological actions of the drugs are
in humans they might or might not be
different than they were an animal
during the animal testing phase this is
the phase at which sponsors begin to
identify the potential side effects of
the drugs and as well as determining the
mechanism of action or MOA how the drug
works in humans and this phase it's not
the point of this phase this phase is
really intended to kind of figure out
what the safety profile is but it's it's
also an opportunity to gain early
evidence on the the effectiveness or the
efficacy of the truck so then once phase
one studies have been completed as I
mentioned it gets rolled out to more
more individuals more individuals test
the drug the this is the point at which
the efficacy really starts to be studied
and you start determining the sponsor
starts collecting data on the extent to
which the drug is effective and this is
also the point at which starts to kind
of fine-tune what the particular
indication for the drug is and one thing
and we'll get to this in a moment but
the when FDA approves the drug it is
approved for a specific indication and
usually within a specific population of
patients and so this is where it's in
the Phase two trials that you start
figuring out exactly who it is
beneficial to treat and what the
particular indications are that it can
be used to treat this is also the phase
at which short term side effects and
certain risks begin to be evaluated and
as a slide notes these these studies are
usually well controlled and they're very
closely monitored an assuming successful
completion of Phase two trials
you'll move right along to Phase three
again start enrolling farm farmer
subjects into these trials and usually
in the thousands these are well
controlled studies they're out there
almost always blinded double blinded
clinical trials and as mentioned here
they are performed after there's been
evidence gathered during the phase two
trials that suggest the particular the
effectiveness as well as safety of the
drug and this is where it's it's
intended to evaluate the overall benefit
risk profile of the drug which is one of
the big factors the FDA takes into
consideration when determining whether
or not to approve a drug and also as the
indication specific indication is
fine-tuned this is the when you start to
make it prepare the adequate labeling of
the drug and the specific indication
that it's going to be approved to treat
and this is also the phase at which many
people start considering what the
potential Medicare Medicaid
reimbursement profile would be for for
the particular drug so assuming a
sponsor and a drug makes it all the way
through these various phases and not a
whole lot of drugs do but assuming that
all of these phases have been
successfully completed to FDA
satisfaction then the next phase is
submitting the actual new drug
application so these applications are
huge huge huge huge like tens of
thousands of pages and so this is the
opportunity at which hopefully the
sponsor will have been engaging FDA
throughout the process and have will
have had a pre NDA meeting like they did
before they submitted their IND to
figure out how to best package the
information and to address any issues
that FDA might flag at that point
the actual contents of the application
are it's all of the the clinical data
that was developed during all the phase
one through three testing as well as any
literature references and any other site
scientific information again the CMC
information about how the drug is
manufactured and produced and FDA will
go out and inspect the before proving a
drug FDA will inspect the facilities
that are producing the drug to make sure
that it complies with FDA's Good
Manufacturing or GMP standards once a
once the NDA has been submitted
the FDA has 60 days within which it can
determine whether or not it wants to
quote file the application and at that
point they can either file it meaning
basically accepting the application for
official review or they can refuse to
file if there's a deficiency obviously
if there's some big section of the of
the application that's missing that
would that would constitute a refused to
file something that would cause the FDA
to refuse to file the application but
there are other potential concerns that
could also lead FDA to refuse to file
the application assuming that the FDA
does in fact file it the standard time
frame in which FDA will their goal for
reviewing the application is 10 months
and giving an approval decision within
that ten months I'll talk about this and
and shortly there's also a priority
review option for certain kinds of drugs
that are intended to meet an unmet
medical need those are that can be
eligible for a priority review or six
month review and the one of the ways
that FDA can
guarantee that it is it meets these
timeframes as that these the timeframes
are supported by large part by user fees
that are paid by the industry so a long
time ago well I guess people still
probably complain about the FDA review
process and approval times however back
in the early 1990s the drug industry had
just been so fed up with the long wait
times I kind of felt like it was a black
box that black hole they'd submit their
applications and not hear anything or
not have any sort of significant
interaction and so the industry proposed
well how about because in part FDA's
FDA's position was look we don't have
enough people to review to review the
the drug applications and so the
industry's response was well how about
if we give you money will that solve the
problem and so back in the the mid 90s
the very first user fee legislation was
passed for for prescription drugs and
these are it's a lot of money so this
year I think the the filing fee for new
drug applications that requires or that
contain clinical data the user fees a
the fee that you're required to the pay
when you submit your application was
around 2.4 million dollars and then for
those paper NDA's or that don't require
the clinical data that was more in the
range about one and a half million
dollars so these are it's something to
seize that but the exchange for those ft
fees is having predictability in the
review time as well as having
predictability in terms of getting
meetings with the FDA throughout the
review to help speed up the development
and approval process so one other thing
I wanted to briefly mention is
as part of the FDA approval process
there also may be but are not
necessarily there advisory committees
who will review the the proposed drug
and opine on whether or not they believe
the risk benefit ratio
excuse me profile is sufficient to
approve to support approval the advisory
committee doesn't have an official say
in whether or not FDA approves a drug
however they will oftentimes their
recommendations are with the FDA
ultimately adopts so moving along so if
so when FDA finally approves the drug
after these you know decade-long plus
decade plus long process wanted to
mention that it's not just the drug that
FDA is approving there are conditions a
number of other conditions that come
along with FDA approval so as part of
the FDA approval process I mentioned
that the FDA will inspect the facilities
that are being used to manufacture and
produce the drug and so there's a little
asterisks here next to me and you vac
shirring facilities that's because FDA
doesn't actually approve facilities so
if you ever see somebody say that they
are marketing an FDA there that they
have an FDA approved or an FDA certified
manufacturing facility run for the hills
because they either don't know what
they're talking about or they're blowing
smoke
because there's no such thing as an
fda-approved facility however as I
mentioned FDA does inspect and to ensure
that the facilities are in compliance
with FDA's Good Manufacturing Practice
requirements before they will approve
approve a drug
additionally FDA reviews and approves
proposed names of the drug so one of the
things that FDA does
is ensure that it's the proposed name is
not confusingly similar to a drug that's
already being marketed or does not is
not misleading in any sort of way for
example FDA would never allow you to say
name a drug cancer cures or something
something to that effect it can't be
fanciful or or include any information
that could be perceived as misleading
another thing the FDA approves is the
labeling for the drug so for
prescription drugs there are what are
called package inserts and so that's I'm
sure probably of all if you have a
prescription drug and there's a wadded
up piece of paper in the in the box or
next to the the pill bottle that has a
lot of information that you've probably
never read well take a look at it the
next time all of that is information
that is carefully negotiated with FDA
during the approval process an FDA
approves all of the information that is
included in that as part of the drug
approval process FDA will also it won't
doesn't for most most of the time it
doesn't require approving the
promotional materials but it's all smart
companies will submit their promotional
materials to have FDA review and approve
them to make sure they're in compliance
with FDA's very stringent stringent drug
promotional requirements so in addition
once you've gone through all of this
you're not off the hook yeah there's a
wide range of post market or post
approval requirements that drug
manufacturers are required to comply
with so mentioned that the facilities
that manufacture the drug are approved
before the drug is approved well they
are also routine
inspected to make sure that the G MPs
are continuing to be followed
historically that happened every two or
so years now FDA is pivoted more to a
risk-based model so for either
facilities that have been out of
compliance or market higher risk for
pursuing manufacturer higher risk drugs
FDA might inspect those facilities more
frequently and use its limited resources
to focus on the bad actors or the higher
risk types of drugs in addition drug
sponsors for approved NDA's are required
to report at adverse events very strict
reporting requirements regarding
regarding adverse events the of which
they become aware and there's
obligations to monitor literature for
potential adverse events and report
those to FDA some of the more serious
ones have to be reported with a two-week
time frame so it's there's a lot of
companies will have or they should have
a very robust pharmacovigilance plan in
place and then as well if there are any
sorts of changes that the sponsor wants
to make on to the drug either if the
sponsor is interested in marketing the
product for additional indications if
they've started gathering research to
support the use and additional
populations or for other uses that would
require submitting a supplement to the
NDA to receive FDA approval for that as
additional indication it also covers
labeling sometimes FDA will require
changes to the labeling based on adverse
event reports if there's new information
that it receives or the sponsor receives
that FDA believes should be included on
the package insert or in the labeling
after you can also request those kinds
of changes additionally if you change
your suppliers or the manufacturing
processes those considers will often
require a either price
our approval or prior notification to
the agency of those kinds of changes so
you're thinking wow this is great this
is a lot of terrific information but I'm
here to learn about candidates so what
does all this mean in the cannabis space
so I one of the points that I wanted to
make was I want you all to understand
how FDA regulates drugs this is based on
the paradigm that was given to the FDA
by Congress through the Food Drug and
Cosmetic Act and there's a lot of ways
in which cannabis and cannabis derived
medical that uses and therapies don't
really quite fit in to the FDA's
existing paradigm but that's not to say
that they can't or don't so
FDA is very keenly aware that that
cannabis holds a lot of promise for
treatment of a number of different
conditions however there are no FDA
approved drugs that contain a plant
derived cannabinoid or and the obviously
cannabis itself is not approved by the
FDA for medical use nor is any plant
derived therapy so it's not been
approved for any indication now you'll
see I use the word marijuana here
because this is FDA references the
Controlled Substances Act which
schedules marijuana but this would be
the same for there's there's no
currently approved marketing
applications for that are derived from
industrial hemp either there are a
number of they're three three different
NDA's approved and then one one aMDA
that are approved for synthetic versions
synthetic cannabis
these are all THC synthetic THC or
chemical compound related to THC and
it's the drugs are Marinol that's the
most that was the one that was approved
back in the 80s I believe and subsequent
to that there have been approvals for
syndra's and most recently
excuse me sesame and then miss recently
sinned rose and FDA's position and this
is one of the reasons that it
recommended to DEA there was part of its
review of clinical data and existing
scientific research as requested by DEA
in response to the petition to
reschedule marijuana FDA did not they
did not believe that there is sufficient
clinical well controlled studies that
have been conducted or at least not when
they reviewed the evidence several years
ago that would support rescheduling and
so although FDA understands that there
are great potentials in for cannabis
therapies today their position is we
just need more data so a few things
about you conducting research with with
cannabis it's not just the FDA that gets
involved of course there's always the
DEA and the DEA this would happen for
any kind of controlled substance not
just not just cannabis but also any kind
of controlled substance the DEA the the
individuals are the the investigators
and the CRO the the people that are
conducting the research need to register
and like be inspected by the DEA to to
be approved to essentially their concern
is more about preventing diversion into
the black or gray market so there would
be DEA is involved with approving the
facilities
the investigators that handle the wood
handle the cannabis and there's also the
registration of the protocol itself so
remember many many slides ago and we
were talking about the study protocol
DEA is also involved in reviewing that
to make sure that complies with all DEA
requirements and so then they're
additional for any kind of schedule one
research that's happening there
additional very very very stringent anti
diversion requirements that are in place
crazy
locks and security and steel cages and
the like very strict controls over who
is allowed to have access to the
Schedule one substance and the like and
so as the IND of during the IND
development phase before the clinical
research can happen the DEA also has to
weigh and approve those individuals to
possess and and administer the
controlled substance as well when it
comes to this is one area where cannabis
is very unique there is only one place
that one place in the United States the
University of Mississippi that grows
quote research grade marijuana for
clinical use in the United States and so
in addition to getting FDA approval of
your int and getting DEA approval of the
investigators and the research sites
you'd also need to get figure out where
to get the cannabis and for this for
clinical trials conducted in the United
States NIDA through a contract at the
University of Mississippi is the only
entity that is lawfully able to provide
marijuana for clinical for clinical
research now it's in the United States
it's a little bit different analysis
when it's outside the United States but
my understanding is that there have been
there have been individuals who want to
study cannabis gone through all the FDA
approval gone through the DEA approval
and then they've just been waiting
waiting waiting waiting on NIDA to
provide the particular strain strength
and dosage form of the of the cannabis
for their for their use and I've I've
also remember reading a Washington Post
article maybe last year that was
basically questioning the quality of the
of the cannabis and also noted that it
had certain pesticide residues and
certain mold content so but that is
where one can lawfully obtained research
grade cannabis in the United States so
kind of looping back to the FDA piece of
the puzzle so I'd mentioned that FDA
understands and is aware of the
potential therapeutic use for cannabis
FDA has stated that it is doing
everything within its existing
regulatory paradigm to help encourage
scientifically valid research in this
space so some of the examples that
they've given of how they have been
supporting cannabis research that goes
through the FDA it has to go through the
FDA approval process FDA final revised
and then finalized a guidance on using
botanical drugs
excuse me botanicals as the source of
drugs and the the primary focus of that
is figuring out how to produce
consistent and reproducible quantities
of the drug product for use in
supporting the drug application in
addition FDA a state
that has been working with potential
sponsors and potential sponsors on
helping them I identify and use some of
the available existing tools the FDA
hazardous disposal to help speed drug
develop developments and these include
orphan drug orphan disease designation
which is for drugs that are intended to
treat very very very small excuse-me
diseases that affect very very small
numbers of people
there's also priority review that is
available for again is for some unmet
drugs that are intended to treat an
unmet medical need as well as various
other sundry categories including
neglected tropical diseases and and
drugs intended for medical
countermeasures and the like and then
FDA has also stated that they have are
really taking efforts to appropriately
staff their botanical drugs team and
make them available and with
interactions with sponsors and potential
sponsors and companies that are
interested in pursuing FDA approval for
potential canopies excuse me for
potential approval and so FDA is is
taking the position that they are using
everything all of the tools that are at
their disposal currently to help
companies that want to go through the
FDA drug approval process to give them
the resources that they need to
basically play by FDA's rules so I have
mentioned kind of alluded to this
process earlier but just to walk you
through how how research should be
conducted with with marijuana marijuana
so the first step would be to contact
FDA again frequent and frequent
interaction with the FDA is is critical
in ensuring
a successful application and I think
just also less frustrating process so
contacting the FDA obtaining a pre-ind
number from the FDA taking that to NIDA
well it says or another DEA registered
source here on this screen and so the
NIDA the University of Mississippi is
not the it's not written in law that it
is it holds a monopoly on it it just de
facto does that the present time FDA is
excuse me DEA has stated that it is
accepting has been accepting
applications for additional growers who
want to who want to grow and provide
research grade cannabis for use in human
research but to my knowledge there have
been there have been no other sites
approved so although it says here
another DEA approved source for right
now it's just nighttime and so that is
this goes back to the CMC information
basically wanting to make sure that the
the drug that's being studied satisfies
all of FDA's Good Manufacturing Practice
requirements and then after after that
step the next step would be to contact
the DEA for the to become appropriately
registered and for the appropriate
licensure as a Schedule one researcher
and then if if applicable and not isn't
always the the sponsor would obtain from
night a letter of authorization to
basically to reference the night as Good
Manufacturing Practices so they kind of
incorporate how night it doesn't they'll
say that's theirs that's how we're going
to
make sure the product is being
appropriately manufactured it is by
reference tinnitus standards and then
the sponsor would submit the the IND
protocol including that letter of
authorization if applicable - but the
FDA and DEA FDA would review that IND in
accordance with the the process and
steps that I described earlier and and
then the sponsor then after that step
number seven if you're still with me
here the sponsor would contact NIDA or
the other regular the other source to
obtain the marijuana for use in the
clinical trials and so there are
multiple steps involved here that are
not these are unique for for in the
cannabis space some of these apply to
other drug therapies but not all of them
so and then quickly before we wrap up I
wanted to mention talk a little bit more
about botanical drugs and FDA reviews me
review an approval of botanical drugs
and the final guidance that FDA is
issued to help companies that are
interested in submitting a drug
application for drugs that are derived
from botanical sources so this is the
FDA's definition of what constitutes a
botanical drug it includes vegetable
material including any kind of plant
material algae fungi any kind of
combination thereof it can come in
various different kinds of dosage forms
and if the if the active ingredients if
to get to the active ingredients there's
not all fermentation but most kinds of
fermentation processes or if the
products are highly distilled purified
or chemically modified
that would not be considered to be a
botanical drug product so some of the
unique in terms of submitting an IND
for for botanical drugs it's pretty much
the same as the ID process that we
described earlier but there are certain
unique characteristics that can impact
the kind of information that a sponsor
would need to submit to the FDA because
plants are not as easily controllable as
you know compounds in a lab the the
heterogeneity of
the sources of the plant material and
the potential variations in the active
ingredients or the constituent elements
of the plants are either difficult to
identify or they're not very well
characterized they do not fully
understood how the how the activities of
those ingredients how they act so
there's a lot of unique challenges that
that are present for botanical drugs
that's more you know chemical based
drugs don't have to don't have to deal
with and so those kinds of things would
need to be addressed in the IND and
again for companies that are interested
in submitting an IND for cannabis for
types of cannabis therapies or therapies
derived from the cannabis plant they be
well served by meeting with FDA reaching
out to FDA early to understand what
kinds of controls chemistry the CMC
controls would need to be in place so a
few of the idea I've alluded excuse-me
alluded to these in the last slide but
some of the unique challenges for
botanical drugs including cannabis Drive
therapies because of the heterogeneity
and potential uncertainty about the
active constituents there are
there are certain controls that need to
be put in place and kind of different
solutions that the companies need to
identify before seeking FDA approval and
so FDA's position is that to ensure a
consistent product across various
batches and lots of the drugs FDA is
taking the position that it could be
supported by a totality of the evidence
how's that for a legal standard that
kind of approach in terms of controlling
the incoming raw botanical materials
that are used to produce the product
certain kinds of manufacturing and
processing controls that need to be in
place in terms of the processing as well
as any sorts of the kinds of assays that
are done to ensure the quality
manufacturing of the product so with
that I have just given a ton of
different information about various
different parts of FDA drug regulation
and how it is I can touch on the
cannabis industry
and how companies considering obtaining
a seeking FDA approval for cannabis
derived therapies the things that they
would need to know in doing so so with
that I'd like to open it up for any
questions Thank You Emily for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button we'll answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for let's get started
our first question is do you think the
FDA will ever actually approve a non
synthetic cannabis drug
I very rarely as a lawyer I very rarely
get to give single word answers that yes
I think I think they will currently
there is a pending orphan drug
application FDA that is has a goal
approval or decision date of this summer
and it is a cannabidiol CBD product
intended to treat childhood epilepsy and
that CBD is not manufactured in a lab it
is extracted from cannabis plants and
it's shown a lot of shown a lot of
progress excuse me a lot of promise and
as I mentioned during my presentation
there it takes a lot to get to even the
NDA application stage and and so the
fact that this drug has already it's in
the NDA stage and is pending approval
from FDA seems like it would it will be
likely to be approved this summer
well thank you we have time for one more
question how does the FDA termina
products Intendant use and what kinds of
claims render a product drug under the
Food Drug and Cosmetic Act sure so the
products intended use FDA will look at
all of the claims that are being made
about a particular product they will
look at product websites they will go to
if if for example a company links to
another another company or a chat board
on their website the FDA will look to
that to see are these things that are
suggesting that the product that the
company marketing this product intends
it to be used in a particular way
because if a company has something on
their website or links to something on
their website even things testimonials
made by customers those can be seen as
the intended use of the product in terms
of the kinds of claims that can you know
turn a drug from excuse me turn a
product from
not a drug into a drug obviously the
most the most kind of egregious example
or the most simple example it would be
cures cancer or treats epilepsy or the
like but there are a wide range of types
of products like for example leaving
alleviating anxiety and things like that
PMS would be considered a disease for
the purposes of determining a health
claim so it's really not just about
cancer Alzheimer's and you know very
very serious things but there are a lot
of different kinds of conditions or
ailments that you and I might not think
of a disease but could make a product
turn a product into a drug if you're
saying that you're going to treat or
help prevent prevent that kind of
condition thank you for that I would
like to once again thank Emily Leon
Jeannie for her presentation would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through June 29th
2018 you'll receive an email from
laberd's letting you know in this
webcast will be available for replay we
share that announcement when your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that is all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye